elon musk i'm not a fan of elon musk for
very legitimate reasons i am not a fan
of the the the technocratic agenda of
many of the people who are in charge of
this country and in charge of really the
world right now
elon musk comes out and says you know i
support the canadian truckers yet he's
developing technology that makes
self-driving cars i am against
self-driving cars just because we can
have the technology to do something
doesn't mean that is a good idea truck
drivers are the number one
uh job here in the states basically the
most employed job and you're going to
get rid of those for self-driving people
what are you going to do hollow out the
entire middle class of this country by
doing that the middle of america you
know there's the stuff with the
neurolink and the brain chips and
improving humanity
i just think there are too many problems
with elon musk as a guy he also has
ties to the ccp and many investments
there i and you know i love what he's
doing with twitter i think that if he
can make it a free speech platform for
all that's a great thing and i'm not
going to knock him for it but i'm not
going to be this person who comes and
just stands
uh stands with with elon musk through
everything because he said some funny
jokes about elizabeth warren it's like
that i don't really care i care about
what's actually getting done and what's
happening in the future
that's what means the most to me
i just like elon's twitter
[Music]
welcome to episode 148 of my podcast i'm
michaela peterson this was a fun episode
i hosted will witt who you might know
from the prageru videos of will
interviewing people in the street or
public campuses he's a nationwide
speaker author and the host of will wit
live on prageru where he talks about
political and cultural issues
we talked about a bunch of topics like
florida's recent don't say gay bill elon
musk buying twitter will's book tour and
the stunning dutch fiance and how he
went from full-blown atheist to
christian i hope you enjoy this episode
and remember to subscribe if you feel
like it
this episode was brought to you by
rabbit air
i'm currently
dying of allergies in tennessee i
thought nashville was great
and it is there's music and cowboys and
blonde girls and short shorts
but it's not great if you have tree
allergies or are a bubble person like me
i've had bronchitis off and on basically
the entire time i've been here which is
also why i've missed a few podcasts
super fun the only thing that's mildly
helped me are these air filters
[Music]
did you know that the air indoors
is up to five times more polluted than
outside
if it weren't for things like these air
filters i would literally be dead
already
which is why i use rapid air i got
rabiter's bio gs 2.0 and my sleep
improved instantly rabid air's newest
model the a3 has a six stage filtration
system that covers up to
1070 square feet
the best thing about these by far though
is how beautiful they are
i think their new a3 model takes the
cake rabbit air is known for winning the
world's most prestigious design awards
so you don't have to look like a nerd
when you're using an air filter to
survive they have a perfect mix of slick
design and top-notch engineering i
really couldn't ask for anything better
than rabbit air other than someone who
could kill all the trees in tennessee
mine has my logo on it too
isn't that cool
i recommend everyone get an air filter
even if you don't have allergies you
won't want to go back once you try them
do your lungs a favor and visit
rabbitair.com today they have a
five-year warranty free shipping and
returns and a 90-day money-back
guarantee on all their products that's r
r-a-b-b-i-t-a-i-r
like rabbit hair like a bunny dot-com
for some of the best air purifiers
you'll find no matter where you look
i hope you enjoy this episode
[Music]
well went welcome to my podcast hey
thanks so much for having me on
thanks for coming on we should have done
this a long time ago but we didn't so
now's as good a time as any i suppose
yeah i'm excited to be on you know we've
been talking for a long time trying to
figure out things with your dad and
things for podcasts and stuff so i'm
glad that finally i'm able to come on
your podcast after you came on mine
yeah
yeah okay before we get started for
anyone who isn't familiar with you and
your work
can you give a brief description of who
you are and what you do
yeah i work for prageru so i create
video content for them have about 700
million views on my videos done a lot of
men on the street videos social media
content i'm also a international speaker
national best-selling author of my book
how to win friends and influence enemies
directed a couple short documentaries
and
that's about it just a conservative
commentator cultural commentator that's
that's really what i do
have you ever taken my dad's personality
test do you know how disagreeable you
are
yes actually so this is funny my my
fiance and i we actually did do the
personality test and i think i was in
like the 99th percentile for
disagreeableness like very disagreeable
um it was like that for the
aggressiveness as well on some of the
the higher end kind of things so which
is strange because if you watch my
videos interviewing people i'm very nice
to people but i guess when it comes to
more my personal life then i can be very
disagreeable very stubborn
okay that doesn't surprise me at all i
scored
i scored zero percentile on politeness
on that test and then i retook it and
was like yeah and then i scored sixth
percentile so that was
that was a little bit better but you
come
is that saying you're not polite
um
it's hard to say so agreeableness like
it splits um your personality into five
personality traits uh openness
conscientiousness extroversion
agreeableness and neuroticism and
agreeableness splits into
uh politeness
oh my gosh this is terrible i don't
think i can remember the other one oh
and compassion
which i actually scored high end so
that's fine but politeness is the one
it's kind of named badly politeness if
you score low in it you're less likely
to
appreciate authoritative figures or
authority figures so you're less likely
to trust authority which just means you
i think it just means you think for
yourself
but right now
i think i scored about the same as you
and i also scored very low in
neuroticism
okay that's good that's probably why
you're calm and nice to people if you're
not flustered easily
right right no i keep my cool in all
those situations that's how you change
people's minds
ah okay so is that what you put in your
book about how you influence enemies did
you just stay calm just be chill
well basically i mean if you're having a
conversation with someone you're trying
to change their mind i mean i found the
best way to do it is by asking people
questions and you can weave the facts
and things into your questions but i
mean i'm sure you've you've debated
people i've debated people when you get
there and you get angry or you're just
trying to shout facts at someone and
it's a very bad way to actually try and
change people's minds when you start
letting your emotions get into it and
i'm not really the type of conservative
who's like facts don't care about your
feelings and that's where we have to go
that's not really what i'm saying but
it's more like okay if you're gonna have
a good conversation with someone then
you have to be able to stay calm you
have to be able to ask questions that
are not going to just tell them what to
think but have them think for themselves
and say okay i couldn't answer this
guy's question maybe i should do some
more research on my own even if you
don't change that person's mind right
there where you are they have to then
say okay i don't know how to answer this
guy's questions i'm going to go home and
you know maybe watch some videos or
whatever it might be to find out
okay so you're just trying to get people
to think until they're stumped and
they're like wait a minute the logical
fallacy somewhere here
yeah basically it's more of a a stump
kind of thing than like a hey hey look
at this stupid liberal who i just
embarrassed on this video it's more like
i want to change this person's mind or
at least if i'm not changing this
person's mind the people who are
watching might learn something or at
least have a tactic that they can use to
go out and talk to people
hmm
interesting
okay
i don't know if i do that very much i
don't think i care enough about any like
one topic
i think to just to bother with it like
yeah that's what you think okay i don't
i don't really and i don't think i enjoy
debate to be honest
yeah it's not all that fun the debating
i mean i'll find that when i go out on
the street and i get someone who's very
angry with me like we went to
this this protest in glendale the other
day it was a teacher's union protest so
there were teachers and parents who were
protesting the saying we want lgbt
education in our schools and i got all
these people who know me and they're
coming up and saying if you will prageru
you're the worst and all these terrible
things calling me just homophobe like
they wouldn't have conversation with me
a lot of them just wanted to debate me
and yell at me and like those types of
conversations it's just not fun it's not
fun to just have someone come up and
already have this preconceived notion of
you and then just try and
dunk on you that way and i don't want to
do it back to them i want to have good
conversations so those types of things
yeah i mean i feel i feel the same way
it's not fun
so you said they were protesting in
order to have lgbtq
education in schools isn't it already in
schools what what's the need for a
protest there or was glendale something
else
yeah i mean especially in california
it's definitely in schools glendale's
like a suburb
in los angeles there's like burbank
glendale some some other ones there so
it's a suburb they have their own uh
school board and all that
so there was there was all these things
that came out in the daily caller about
leaked emails between upper board
members talking about conservatives are
the worst and we're going to push this
stuff on kids and so then there are all
these people coming after the disney
stuff saying well we need to support
this and make sure that it doesn't get
shut down in in california and so that's
really what they were there for and you
know so much of it is just co-coded in
the sense of oh this is about love this
is about acceptance we're here to make
sure that children can be whatever they
want and then you get down to it and you
start looking at the books that they're
pushing on people you look at how
they're telling kids not to tell their
parents about it and thinking that
parents always have a skewed view and
are the devil
they're they're easily able to lie about
what they're actually teaching to try
and make it seem like this loving
movement when when i got there i mean
they they were incredibly hateful
towards me
so you mentioned something about disney
can you fill me in on the details i
don't know if i'm aware of what's going
on
yeah so i mean in florida with disney
and all the other things that ron
desantis has done like he's basically
done the don't say gay bill as they call
it where
okay so sorry i'm going to slow you down
i'm i don't i have no idea how i'm not
super aware of this because i really
should be because i have a podcast i
haven't podcasted a lot it's been like
three months i feel like i haven't been
doing anything other than like computer
work what is the desantis don't say gay
bill can you give me the background
let's start with that then go into
disney and then
go from there
yeah basically the don't say gay bill is
a bill that was signed by desantis that
essentially says hey we don't want this
lgbt education being taught to kids up
to third grade in public school and so
now you are not allowed to teach that
type of education to children up to
third grade in florida and i think i
mean i think it's an amazing win and so
but the way that the left handle i mean
it's not called the don't say gay bill
that's not what it's really called
that's what the left has used as their
moniker for it saying oh in florida you
can't say gay anymore you can't say the
word gay around kids otherwise you might
go to jail like this level of
exaggeration that these people have and
so that's where i really spawned from
from from that and then with disney
there was disney that was pushing the
lgbt content in their movies and so and
many of their other products
and so desantis decided to get rid of
disney's tax status as basically their
own entity in the state of florida so
that now they have to pay taxes and and
don't have their own entity just like
any other business in the state which i
think disney ended up losing 35 billion
dollars
yeah so that's really what happened
yeah yeah
wow wow
good for that guy
huge serious yeah i don't know how
anybody could argue that they should be
teaching that stuff to people under
third grade that's so unreasonable as it
is you don't teach sex ed to kids under
third grade i think right i don't think
i learned about it until fourth grade
in canada
i think i learned in fifth grade
yeah that seems totally reasonable wow
okay so they were outside about disney
yeah again it's not even the it's they
say that it's about love and acceptance
and that's what they're teaching but
when you look at the materials and you
see what's in there and you see some of
these videos of tick-tocker teachers
that are coming out and saying like oh
yeah we have this transition closet at
our school and the kids can come in
change their clothes in my classroom and
then don't tell your parents about it
that's what's being taught you know that
that's what's really horrible about it
it's really insidious because i mean
it's being pushed on children so much
that
i think desantis did exactly the right
thing i wish other people would do more
like what the santas did
do you think he's going to stay in power
in florida
in terms of winning the next election or
you mean going into running for office
as president
um well i mean that i've heard i've
heard rumors about that but i mean just
staying in power in general or do you
think florida's doomed like the rest of
the country
no i think florida's i think florida is
on the right path more than almost any
other state except for maybe idaho the
lady in idaho today who's within the
government there just said that they
want idaho to be this this christian
state founded on christian values i mean
it was like it was very based right and
now but i think governor desantis is
doing everything right in florida where
he's coming and saying listen i don't
care what the left says about me i don't
care what these people on social media
say about me i don't care what the new
york times writes about me i'm going to
do what is best for my people and that's
what he's doing and every single
conservative basically that i know of
except for maybe like the national
review types of people say desantis is
just the best because he's doing things
that conservatives haven't done since
ronald reagan really and that's winning
and conservatives have really forgot how
to win in basically every sense of the
word
yeah okay that's interesting where are
you right now where are you based
i'm in la yeah i'm in la so definitely
not like florida no unfortunately yeah
no it's hell on earth here
yeah how do you manage to survive in
california
you must feel stifled
i do feel stifled but it is also
enjoyable with
all the people around you disagree with
me
being like the black sheep can be kind
of fun you know it's like if if people
all agree with me then i i i do get a
little bit
antsy in the sense that it's not so
interesting to be around people if
everyone's just talking about
conservative politics all the time but
then again as well my quality of life
would go up tremendously if i was living
somewhere else but you know you know
prageru does is based here in l.a so i'm
kind of
i'm kind of shoehorned in for now
okay that's fair so you mentioned
a fiancee
and i swear floating around instagram
i've seen this not to be like objective
about anybody but absolutely gorgeous
girl that turns out to be your fiance
that's
european like some conservative from
europe how did that happen how did you
snag that
yeah conservative from europe is also an
anomaly in and of itself so for me to be
able to find her so actually she she had
met dennis prager at an event in hungary
last september and then she did this
speech in sweden all about covert
mandates and everything like that and
she was she had known who i was so she
sent it to me and she said hey will like
i love your stuff can you review this
speech for me and i said sure like i'll
review it you're beautiful like i'll
look at this
and then i was like well i'll review the
speech for you and tell you what i think
but i have to call you and tell you
trying to get her number and she's like
okay you can get my number but you have
to ask dennis prager for it so i asked
dennis prager for her number got her
number and then basically said don't
ever doubt me again and then that's how
that's how it all started from then and
so then i was able to to get out to
europe and see her and just
it's really been incredible she's the
most incredible woman i've ever met
that's awesome i'm so happy for you
that's so fun thank you thank you it was
fun to take the personality test
together that was a good time
did you hook them together
you know you can loop them together and
i mean yeah you can do it yourself but
to compare results yeah we did the
comparison results thing and so the
thing that is so great about her and i i
know some people i don't know people
disagree with this her and i are very
very similar we're like the same person
and some in some ways it's f it's like
i've fallen in love with myself
even more than i already could and so
her and i are very very similar and in
many of the categories we were quite the
same on our politics we're basically
exactly the same we don't disagree on
much we have very similar values and so
when we did the test we were like wow
like even just based on this test were
very similar and i think that's a good
thing i think it's a good thing to be
similar to the person that you're with
especially if you're in a place like
like me or you or or what she's doing
and you you need someone when you're
getting so much hate all the time you
need someone who's going to be a fan of
yours
i think that the person who you you
marry should be your number one fan and
they should they should really be on
your side that's that's what i think
yeah i completely agree i also agree
with the
somebody similar to yourself although i
think that also depends on what type of
personality you have like you're
probably hyper conscientious so being
with someone else who's hyper
conscientious is like necessary or
they're just going to torture you to
death right right you're not going to
want to go anywhere they're not going to
have any drive they're going to be messy
and you're just going to be like
disgusted so i think like if you're
hyper conscientious you have to be with
someone else who's hyperconscientious um
if you're extroverted you probably
should be with someone else who's
extroverted or you're going to want to
talk to people and they're not going to
watch you and then agreeableness is the
interesting one so because you struck
you strike me right off the bat as
someone who's low in agreeableness
otherwise you wouldn't be able to do
what you do
and it's really rare for a female to
also be low in agreeableness it's like
more rare it's not super rare um but
even me i said um agreeableness splits
into two and my compassion is really
high my politeness is really low so it
puts me at pretty much average
um
which i think is good but
for someone with your personality and
say finding someone similar would be
super fun
otherwise yeah
yeah
yeah she's very low on agreeableness as
well which which hasn't caused any
problems to be honest it's been it's
been great because we see things that
are going on yeah i mean we see things
going on and we both go very strong on
them which has been great and since we
don't really disagree on much
uh
there's no like contention there where
we're butting heads because we're both
stubborn or anything like that so it's
all worked out really
well how do you guys feel okay i'm just
gonna have to get we already talked
about this online i'm just gonna have to
get you both on but we'll do that in
person at some point i'm planning on
moving to miami so
and i'll have a studio there so we can
do that
uh we can do that then where was i going
with this i'm moving to miami because
i've got these terrible tree allergies
and so it's giving me a brain fog it's
making me less productive and i cannot
have that like
i need not allergic to anything
that's
that's amazing
yeah it is that's amazing what is like
why that's so unfair do you know how
much easier your life is well like
forget about being white and male the
fact that you're not allergic to
anything
i know it's a much higher appreciate
that yeah yeah oh i really do but i i
have enough of my own health problems i
mean i have i have gout which is
terrible you know the carnivore diet
have you heard of the carnivore diet
will of course i have listen i i've been
doing the carnivore diet in a little bit
i mean i'm still i'm doing it somewhat i
mean i've basically done the carnivore
diet my whole life because vegetables
are disgusting
but
i i'm getting like i've just been eating
cheeseburgers
every day for the past week and i think
it's great isn't it
no no bun no buns just just a
cheeseburger okay i would try that but
i'd like seriously for gout gauss
unpleasant i and my arthritis was kind
of gowdy
um i drop the dairy and see like drop
the dairy and see what happens dairy was
a huge huge problem for my arthritis
the cheese makes it taste so good though
it changes the the whole thing
i
you could try it for like three weeks
just see what happens and then eat a
bunch of cheese and see what happens
no i'll try i think the my at least my
doctor said the number one thing is the
alcohol is to not be drinking that
causes the inflammation
yeah
so i don't know i don't know if i buy
that yeah what are you doing
i don't think i don't think that's the
problem i think it's the dairy you
should do a test go go dairy list for a
month and eat a bunch of dairy and see
what happens go alcohol from
alcoholism for a month and then have
some vodka sodas and see what happens
right but that means on the days that
i'm not doing dairy i just need to drink
a lot every day
to really test out the theory
that could work i'm just i'm just
actually telling you this because i'm
going to be putting out a hangover pill
which is going to discredit me further
which i'm you know i'm prepared for
so i'm really just like alcohol's not
bad and then later i'm going to come out
and be like here's my hangover pill
wait what do you mean a hangover bit
like something you developed
okay okay i'm going to sell you on this
but it's legit it's not available yet so
you could go out and buy it even though
i'm not selling it yet the um
the herb's called dihydromyricitin
which isn't super catchy so i'm going to
rename it after party which is way
catchier but it's called that almost
sounds like a drug
yeah well anyway i was um i was in
pretty rough shape in university and i
was drinking a lot and i was lying in
bed one day and i was like this is the
level of hangover no human should
experience and it's 20 like 11 2012.
someone must have come up with a
hangover pill so i say so i started
doing some research and i found
dihydromyricitin and i found studies
they'd done on rats and so they take
these poor rats and they pump them full
of alcohol and then they do maize tests
so they'll do maze tests with sober rats
and they'll do this one test where they
flip the rat on its back and wait to see
how long it takes to write itself so
that's another test they'll do the mace
test and then they'll do a drowning test
so how long does a rat swim before it
just gives up swimming and they have
their
one group which is just normal rats and
then they have their really drunk rats
and then they have the rats that are
drunk but they've also given
dihydromyricitin
and the difference between the rats that
were just drunk and had dihydromyrest in
were massive you can just read it in the
study is they had less anxiety going
through the maze so they go through the
maze quicker they write themselves
faster and they take longer to drown
and i was like that's pretty interesting
so i started finding the compound online
and i started taking it when i was like
20 and it made a massive difference to
my hangovers because i used to get just
brutally awful hangovers because i used
to drink too much
anyway
there's more research on it that it
works weekly on gaba
and you get a gaba crash after you drink
so you can get like anxiety
with the
website
yeah something's here there you go yeah
um and so it works weekly on gaba which
means it's not
scary like a benzodiazepine it doesn't
saturate the receptors but it works
weakly enough that it'll reduce the
anxiety but it also
increases how fast you metabolize
alcohol and how easily you break it down
it's ma it's this magical herb
um
and so i'm coming out with that but i
actually do believe that the gout thing
would benefit a lot from reducing dairy
and i don't think vodka is the problem
there's like nothing in vodka
yeah no grain left like it's it's just
it's like ethanol
yeah you see i almost feel like the the
hangover
is god's punishment for people doing
stupid things i almost feel like we
shouldn't make a hangover pill
to make people have to pay for their
mistakes
see
i i like partly agree with you but then
you try the hangover pill and you're
like well god probably also made this
pill for the people who do the research
yeah right yeah
there's a lot of things i think you're
right it's yourself
yeah no i i would definitely do the
hangover pill if you if you developed it
i think that would be a life i'll send
it to you it is it is i'll send it to
you when it's out
okay
the older you get it gets worse
oh yeah i didn't have like i had
miserable hangovers forever but i didn't
have the uh anxiety and now it's like
brain fog too
and it's not like it's a hangover cure
but it reduces it i think by about 80
percent so if you do go out to a party
or something
you're not screwed up for like
you know two days minimum
right yeah no i'll definitely try it
that'll be a lifetime life changer for
me because the hangovers ruin like an
entire day the entire next day is gone
yeah because of it and then you can't
work
yeah exactly yeah yeah it's it's not not
doable uh okay so you
went on a book tour right recently
yeah all over how did you manage that in
covid
well so the way that we did it is that
we worked with turning point usa first
of all and so turning point usa kind of
sponsored the tour and so they reached
out to a lot of student groups across
america and said hey if any of you guys
want to bring will out for an event you
can fill out this form and then we're
going to kind of put them all together
for a book tour and so i was able to do
most of them on campus so i did i did
one month or a month and a week of book
touring and so that was the longest i've
ever been on the road i mean it was it
was a really tough time going to be
honest with you i mean i'm sure you know
you and your dad and everything know
about the touring and what it's like i
mean it's it can be just
there's nothing more exhausting than
doing that you know when you got to wake
up and travel and then do it all again
and you're doing interviews the whole
time selling the book
it's quite difficult and so i did a lot
of them on campus and then i did a few
private events of people who i knew who
wanted to sponsor me some in tampa utah
texas things like that and then on the
weekends i was doing churches so there
really was yeah so there really wasn't a
dull moment it was pretty it was every
single day for a month and a week a new
city and event
yeah kind of makes you sick of traveling
huh
yeah no i i didn't travel for a month
after that i stayed home i was like this
is this is i'm so exhausted and it
wasn't even just exhaustion i mean truly
going on that book tour and i think
there's a degree of of ptsd that comes
from something like that i don't want to
try and self-diagnose myself or anything
like that but but when you're at events
and you're getting hundreds and hundreds
of people coming up to you and loving
everything you're doing or you know
you're getting all those dopamine hits
and you're doing these huge events and
then you go home and there's not that
anymore it's a really strange feeling
i i'm sure you guys can relate it's it's
a it's a strange thing to have to deal
with
yeah that's interesting i think i like
um first of all i haven't done a tour
like that and so i did a bunch of the
shows i opened for a bunch of my dad's
shows and so i think it's a bit
different because people were there to
see him
so i didn't have
and then i also knew how exhausted i was
even just doing that because of the
traveling and then with this ridiculous
diet i'm on adding that into the mix
like not fun i have avoided
uh it's too late i've already said it
like i avoided a lot of the interactions
because i knew that's a huge of the
amount of the draining part right it's
just it's exhausting talking to a lot of
people especially because people have
like really intense stories i'm sure you
saw us come
at you and they tell you this incredible
intense story and it's like it's
emotionally
it's hard emotionally and so i think it
and so even though i avoided that part i
was exhausted dad
dad was super exhausted but he's got
like an endless supply of energy somehow
yeah yeah i can imagine i mean it's
really difficult and it's great you get
to meet so many people i mean i met
thousands and thousands of people going
on this tour all
and they're just the best people i mean
to come out and come to an event like
that and come buy books and do the
signing
these are amazing people it's so great
to meet all them and the fact that i
have any fans at all it just blows me
away every single day and so
it's great to go and do those things but
it is draining there's nothing more
exhausting until you tour
yeah it's it's wild too because i hadn't
you don't think about it right you don't
think about it until you're kind of on
it
um
and i was always shocked i remember i
bought tickets to see somebody and they
got sick and i was like oh how could
they get sick it's like oh no they're
just like a person touring they're very
likely to get to get sick but um i've
met a couple of musicians who toured
who toured for like years and they
didn't have a home like their life was
touring and they didn't have a home and
by the time they were 30 they were just
like screwed
like one person i talked to they're like
i almost died like it almost killed me i
was living on a bus and i was in an
airplane and i was a had a show every
night
and
like and now he's like done
i guess it's rough
yeah i think i think it adds
yeah i really think it adds a level of
almost depression when it's when it's
over
because it's just so much you're doing
so much and then it's done you're not
there and it's like wow what am i
supposed to do now i don't have all
these people i'm not giving a speech i'm
not selling my books
it it bums you out for sure
there's a level today my dad had that i
think my dad had that and i was always
like you have a lot too cause i'm like i
manage his
brand it was that's a simple way of
putting it and so when he whenever he
stopped her and he's like i don't know
what to do i was like no we can feel
like you have lots to do we don't overdo
it like you have a podcast you could
record every day if you wanted to you
have books to your writing like
there's more than that like but you you
know you don't want to cram your
schedule to death but i mean maybe it
was just the entire social aspect and
then having that cut
that is yeah i i think so
i think that i think
there's something weird that goes on
your brain i can't tell i can't not a
neurologist or anything to say exactly
what happens but i know that there is
something difficult about seeing so many
people and having so many people be fans
of what you're doing to then go to not
having that
and to just be at home in your apartment
with your dog
watching youtube and and being like wow
what the hell is going on now what am i
supposed to do now
it's a strange feeling
that's interesting yeah and i suppose
there are no studies done on that
this episode was sponsored by bio
optimizers the folks at bio optimizers
have done it again they've just released
their new formula for magnesium
breakthrough the most potent magnesium
supplement on the market if you struggle
with anxiety depression have trouble
sleeping or are just overworked and
stressed try magnesium
even before you try meditation maybe
it's much faster you can always go back
to meditation seriously though about 50
percent of americans are magnesium
deficient which is crazy because it
helps with all sorts of things from
diabetes muscle relaxation and blood
pressure to metabolism and digestion
there's a reason it's called our body's
master mineral the problem is most
supplements are synthetic or only have a
couple of types of magnesium and let's
be honest how many of us know the
difference between magnesium taurate and
malate
magnesium breakthrough by bio optimizers
has all seven organic forms plus
cofactors to increase absorption
ensuring stress relief and high
cognitive performance
many of their customers immediately
notice the effects be in charge of your
well-being take one before bed every
night and see how you feel in the
morning bio optimizers even has an
exclusive offer to get you started visit
magbreakthrough.com
peterson or use code peterson at
checkout for 10 off it's also a great
gift
magbreakthrough.com
peterson
okay
next subject uh elon musk buying twitter
how do you feel about that
oh we could get really into this one i
mean you responded to my instagram story
the other day that was about dr oz which
we could get into as well but this this
is uh i was like dr oz
i know you like dr oz i i don't agree
with that i think dr oz is is bad for
america
uh in terms of the elon musk stuff
elon musk i'm not much of a fan of
i think that conservatives
how
how just not being are you like that kid
at school that didn't like harry potter
because they're like yeah i don't like
harry potter like yeah you do everyone
likes harry potter
i also didn't like harry potter
no harry potter no harry potter is for
women and children lord of the rings is
for men i watched lord of the rings and
red lord of the rings that was my thing
but you like thrones
not as much as lord of the rings but i
did i read all the books and watched the
show and then it they ruined the show i
mean just terrible game of thrones was
great
the books were so much better you know
what pissed me off about game of thrones
and then we'll get back to elon okay i'm
just gonna say this this isn't this
isn't nice but sansa should have been
hotter in the show like they make this
huge thing about how perfect she is in
the show
that made me mad
i agree she wasn't the most attractive
person didn't she date harry styles the
lady or who did she who did she date the
actress one of the brothers
there was like a band a couple of
brothers wow yeah no i'm not that upset
yeah i don't know
whatever anyway yeah she wasn't the best
looking i mean daenerys was obviously
the best
yeah
and then rob stark's wife before he got
stabbed she was she was beautiful as
well
yeah she should have had her be sansa
except i guess she wouldn't fit with the
description
yeah but they did weights for everyone
else
anyway that was a very important
conversation from a show that ended like
four years ago
watching it it's still really good are
you i want to re-watch it i i would love
to do that yeah i re-watched lord of the
rings about every three months so i
should get on game of thrones as well
and do it
wow every three months jordan made me my
fiance he made me watch lord of the
rings
like the first week we we met i think it
was a test it was like will she do it
like all the movies which i did it was
like extended edition honestly yeah yeah
extended edition you have a good fiance
tv
yeah it was it's a good it's a good show
but there's definitely like i definitely
think it appeals more to men and i have
a pretty masculine personality and i was
still like some of these scenes like
they go on
they just go on and there's a lot of
emotion there too it's like why are why
is there so much emotion in the scene
and who is it appealing to like not
there's not a motherly instinct i don't
think so it must be appealing to
emotions in men which is weird
right it's like when sam is going i
can't carry it for you but i can carry
you and he puts frodo on his back and he
takes him up to mount doom i mean that's
like that's your thinking of your best
friend your brother i mean it's it's
it's truly powerful stuff it's really
the most incredible
anyway okay we don't have to get into
this whole lord of the rings
i could talk about lord of the rings
i've made plenty of videos all about the
lord of the rings about tolkien about
what they're doing with the new amazon
show plenty of stuff oh
yeah
anyway elon
okay we'll go back to elon musk okay
it's a very loose podcast which i like
it's it's interesting that way elon musk
i'm not a fan of elon musk for very
legitimate reasons i am not a fan of the
the the technocratic agenda of many of
the people who are in charge of this
country and in charge of really the
world right now
elon musk comes out and says you know i
support the canadian truckers yet he's
developing technology that makes
self-driving cars i am against
self-driving cars just because we can
have the technology to do something
doesn't mean that it's a good idea truck
drivers are the number one
uh job here in the states basically in
most employed job and you're going to
get rid of those for self-driving people
what are you going to do hollow out the
entire middle class of this country by
doing that the middle of america you
know there's the stuff with the
neurolink and the brain chips and
improving humanity
i just think there are too many problems
with elon musk as a guy he also has
ties to the ccp and many investments
there i and you know i love what he's
doing with twitter i think that if he
can make it a free speech platform for
all that's a great thing and i'm not
going to knock him for it but i'm not
going to be this person who comes and
just stands
uh stands with with elon musk through
everything because he said some funny
jokes about elizabeth warren it's like
that i don't really care i care about
what's actually getting done and what's
happening in the future
that's what means the most to me
i just like elon's twitter
right no he has some funny tweets i want
to be able to
answer emails on my phone while i'm
driving
that sounds like a tie on my priority
list i want that i get that i get that
but you know then you have self-driving
cars and now in europe they're just
putting forward these things and cars
that are saying okay if you get to a
certain speed limit then we can shut you
down right that your car can't go past a
certain speed limit uh that was bound to
happen
yeah and so then it's like a certain
speed limit and then they say okay
actually you've used too much carbon
this month driving so you can't drive
anymore
yeah so it's like all these things go
together and so this type of agenda of
this technological revolution
i think is is truly
is probably the biggest issue for
humanity it's not an american or a left
first right issue it's a humanitarian
issue
i didn't hear about that european car
thing i wonder if my dad knows about
that i'm gonna call him and tell him
after this podcast yeah you should ask
him
yeah it's really terrible and these
things slither in and they always use it
under the guise of oh technology is just
making everyone's life better helping
people and then you think about
people in this country and everyone's so
nihilistic you don't have to go meet
people anymore you can swipe right for
them on tinder you don't have to cook
you can order your food everyone can be
an uber driver and girls can be only
fans models and that's how you make
money i mean i think the the
technological revolution has been
detrimental in a lot of ways to
to to america and the west in general i
mean even capitalism in a sense you know
as a conservative we talk about free
markets all the time but you can't help
but say the free markets and the
industrial revolution drove it so that
people no longer had to put families
first like they used to in in this
country and across the west so there's a
lot of problems with this and but i
don't think a lot of people are waking
up to it
here's a question
sure here's a question so you're a
conservative dude your fiance
is a conservative woman what what's your
opinion on
her role when you guys start having kids
because she has a social media following
of her own
yeah no i i think that a lot of that
we've talked about it before and been
like okay what do you want to do when we
have kids and and you're you're looking
forward to that do you want to stay home
or what do you want to do she
as i said before about her
she is the most incredible woman i've
ever met she transcends what other women
are like she transcends what most men
are like in the way that she thinks
about ideas of the world and of politics
and not just politics but culture and
humanity and history art i mean she's
she's so incredible what i what i would
say and i i hope this doesn't sound
simply i'm trying this is really true i
truly believe this is that
though it would be doing the world a
disservice if she wasn't out there
saying things if she wasn't speaking her
mind because she's so good and so i
think that when it comes to having
children i think that obviously she will
need to prioritize that that will be a
priority and she will love those
children and of course and of course i
will too but you know as the mother she
will have a different role but i think
denying the world her thoughts and
opinions and the things she knows would
be a disservice to everyone else in the
world so i think she has to be able to
do enough of both be able to manage it
while not sacrificing the children for
it
that was so nice that was pretty nice
that was really nice to hear i've talked
to like i talked to a lot of people and
i've been on some i've talked to some i
wouldn't even say conservative men more
like the red pill community men where
they're like women's you know women stay
home and i know a lot of women who
actually like enjoy my best friend
having the time of her life with little
kid my sister-in-law same thing she just
had a little baby she's having the time
of her life although she works as well
but like
and then me and i think it's my and i
honestly think it's my personality um
because i'm driven in a way that i know
a lot of my friends aren't uh if i
change like when i have more kids
because i would really like more kids if
i
stayed home and didn't work i would go
crazy and it would be not good for
anybody
like i'm not able to do it and i've
figured out that i'm able to have a kid
spend really quality time with that kid
it's different when they're really
little like if they're under a year old
they're kind of glued to you and and
that's that but after that i think
depending on what type of woman you are
there is a way to balance it so that
you're able to work and fulfill one side
of yourself that maybe not everybody has
and also have kids and i think
i think it's important to talk about
because i think a lot of women don't
have kids a lot of women who are more
driven don't have children because
they're like well
i'm not going to be able to to do it
right and i think that that's just a lie
that there is a way to do both it's
tricky and it's going to be trickier i
think for a woman than for man because
you're female that's just like how the
world is but i think it's doable
it's good that you guys have talked
about that
yeah i i think that
if you're going to do both you will have
to end up sacrificing parts of each
that's just obviously you only have a
finite amount of time every single day
you have to sacrifice a part of each i
mean i know plenty of women who are
conservative and they they also have
jobs and and also provide for their kids
and you can see some of them have
sacrificed their kids for their career
and the things that they're doing and
it's like if that's if that's what you
want to do i i guess i get it but you
know throughout history i mean
there have been women who have gone to
work throughout history this isn't just
a totally nuanced thing where where
women have stayed home forever but i
think that
i think that women should be
prioritizing kids over the career if
you're saying that you are are splitting
it up and saying okay i'm going to do 50
50. that is only 50 of the time that
your kid is getting with you and i think
that
studies show in in basically every
category that if you want to have good
kids with good values that you should
spend more time with them and that's
also a dad thing that's also a dad thing
dad should come home from work and at
least spend time with their kids not
just go up and go to sleep or watch tv
so it's a it's a it's a tied together
thing both of them have to to put in the
work for their kids i mean this is why i
talk to so many parents uh conservative
parents who say yeah my kids now they're
horrible leftists they're communist
socialists they shave their head or
whatever and i'm like yeah that's partly
your fault that's your fault for not
taking enough interest in your child you
didn't have dinner with them you didn't
sit down and talk to them about your
values you didn't take them to church
it's your fault if you want them to be
good you make them good yourself
yeah and be careful about what school
you put them in right if you're like oh
i don't like what that school is
teaching my kids i don't like their
teacher
that teacher is teaching your kids for
like what is it
nine to three
five days a week
and you don't you don't like that
and you literally have an option here
it's like oh no it's the closest school
and i don't have enough money so it
needs to be a public school find a
different one although to be fair public
schools it's tricky like you said
it's very tricky so
there's a pro there's actually a massive
problem there and not everybody can
homeschool so no it's tricky but i mean
i
and i didn't grow up now nowadays it's
worse but i remember my dad took me out
of class
i don't even remember why because i was
little i was in grade like two three and
four and be like oh you're staying home
this week like why am i staying home
this week but like sweet i'm staying
home this week and i later found out
those were the more like the politically
correct weeks where
guest speakers would come in and teach
you about
i think it was i think it was mostly
like relationships
in a politically correct way and my dad
like from the early ages was like nah
staying home this week like so there i
feel like there are kind of things you
can dodge although it's pretty
intertwined in how people are schooled
now so maybe maybe i'm not being
sympathetic enough to people but i feel
like if you have a strong like
if you're at home and you talk to your
kids and you have dinner and you explain
these things and you say yeah you know
some of the things are going to be
taught aren't true
i've already told scarlett that when she
comes home and she's like is this true
i'm like no well so-and-so said it was
true well people lie
yeah you have to think yeah
the kids aren't gonna know anything that
isn't told to them
and so i i just find it funny that all
these people come and talk about
indoctrination and they say oh you want
to homeschool your kids or you want to
make your kid a christian you want to
indoctrinate them with those values and
it's like
in a way yes i mean not indoctrinate but
i want to i want to give my kids these
values i don't care about what you think
about me leftists i want to push these
values push these values on my kids to
make them good people and then if you if
you send them to public school then
they're just indoctrinated by the
government so would i rather have them
be indoctrinated by me or indoctrinated
by
you teacher who has a transition closet
it seems pretty obvious but they don't
want you to have
i mean there are many people on the left
who don't want you to even have
ownership of your kids some of these
radical wing of the le they want to say
oh the government basically owns your
kids you send them to school the parents
don't get any say and now you're our kid
that's nuts how that's got to be like
it's that transition closet you
mentioned like i know that there are
these tick tocks that go viral that show
some of these awful things but how
frequent do you think that kind of thing
is like that's got to be more on the
rare side don't you think
yeah of course i mean i mean you know
the
you hear something like that and
obviously this isn't in every single
classroom there's no doubt that that's
this is an instance that has been
showcased and it's blowing up on social
media and people are
amplifying it but what you will see is
that there are so many examples of
people who want this taught i mean when
you look at the polling when you look at
all these pictures of teachers when you
look at the amount of people who got mad
at the don't say gay bill in florida
there's plenty of people who are for
this leftist agenda in the schools not
all of them are as radical not all of
them are are coming out to their kids as
they are and and trying to push them
into some ideology some of them just are
teaching a little bit better of course
but there are there are many people and
if you think about it
there let's say that transition closet
is just in one classroom well that's
still one person's kid that's still one
person's kid that could be getting
indoctrinated or being groomed by a
teacher or in many places i think these
are sexual predators
i think that it just needs to be banned
nationwide this type of this type of
behavior this type of education because
it's
it's not for children and it's it's
ruining some kids lives
yeah 100 i'm 100 with you like i don't
know if i'd uh i mean i'm probably
conservative i've always identified as a
libertarian never identified as a
conservative i was like no i'm like i
don't really care as long as everybody
leaves me alone i don't i don't really
care what what goes on out there but
what's good what's going on in schools
and like hormone replacement therapy for
kids that is completely unforgivable
of course and that's why you should hate
dr oz because dr oz pushed for
hormone blockers on kids
what
yeah
yeah no
uh-huh dr oz is when
uh i'd have to look it up but it was a
whole thing i don't believe it
puberty blockers on kids i swear like
you gotta look this up look at how much
fake facts there is about dr oz you know
how much fake news there is about him no
of course
right no i understand but i would
recommend that you you look decide
anyone who's listening look up look up
dr oz in the puberty blockers look up dr
oz being tied to the world economic
forum dr oz not even living in the state
of pennsylvania that he lives in no way
that sounds like conservative nonsense
well i don't know
i don't know nonsense
sorry my asthma from this horrible state
i live in
this um i moved to tennessee in
september and i was like tennessee land
of the free
beautiful wonderful amazing place
and then the trees got me and i've been
like chronically ill for eight months
because i'm allergic to everything and
the trees here bloom all the time so i'm
moving to miami
that's good yeah palm trees they don't
have that same effect
no they don't and it's sunny there yeah
they've introduced this new bill which
sounds nice yes no you're gonna have a
great time with your kids in florida
yeah
yeah
we could go back to that
the libertarian thing
if you wanted to talk about that because
i'm very not libertarian
okay okay why because you think you have
a duty to change
i mean that's fair too i understand that
yeah
why do you not like libertarianism
so think about the far left in itself
right you think about people who are
communists you think about the ideology
of marxism and all of these ideologies
work through force they have to have a
revolution a cultural revolution maybe a
violent revolution whatever it is to get
what they want they have to
have a revolution they have to take
something over they have to convince a
class that they are lower so that they
can come and rise up when you have
libertarians then you now have a people
who say leave me alone against an
ideology that says we're going to take
over and so that is why i think that
america is the way that it is because
we've basically had libertarian like
liberal and libertarian people versus
the left
and the left doesn't take no for an
answer where libertarians just say okay
i'll just leave it alone and so when you
have real conservatism or at least an
ideology that prioritizes families and
and and that sort of sense then you
actually have people pushing back that's
why people like desantis now that's why
a lot of real conservatives like
desantis that's why people like the
country of hungary because they're not
like this this just oh free market like
live and let live type of deal they say
no we are going to do things that are
going to actually benefit our people we
are going to be on the aggressive we are
going to attack instead of just the
the live and live type of art and i
don't mean to attack you or anything for
being a libertarian
just go
my thoughts about libertarianism that
ideology has made it so that
now we have these transit because we
i'll say we just looked at a thing today
from the washington post in 2017 they
were talking about confederate statues
being bad but the founding fathers good
and you go through all the different
timeline and now in 2022 they're coming
out and saying let's change the name of
george washington university and it's
like that's how their ideology works
this washington post saying let's change
george washington university but that's
how their ideology works because it has
to make people believe that there is a
revolution that has to be taken over for
anything to be changed whereas people
who say no let's just make it as free as
possible individualism will always get
ran over by the people who say we need a
revolution
okay i can like i can get behind part of
that and i agree with part of that at
this point and part of the reason i
built a podcast and i have certain
guests on is because i'm trying to push
back against it i completely agree it's
gone too far i probably
started well i was pretty disagreeable
like i was
arguing about feminism you know in grade
nine before it was cool
yeah um but
so i'm probably i think the part of
conservatism conservatism that
that i didn't
that didn't appeal to me was
there were elements of it that i just
wasn't interested in like let's say back
in 2013 when conservatism was more
conservative than it is now because it's
moved over um it was i was always you
know pro
make drugs legal type of thing which i
think a normal conservative would say no
there needs to be
like ban those
but guns are okay and i was like well
guns are also okay but like drugs are
okay and i think i was just i'm just
okay with more things
but the fight element i definitely agree
agree with you like what i i mean i i
left canada i talked about how
the way
covid was handled was ridiculous i
started talking about that i think in
june the first time right before i got
covered the first time like right away i
was like if you can't shut things down
though they can't do that like that's
not gonna go well um
but i see where you're coming from yeah
i'm sorry i like i don't know where i
stand at the moment yeah
i mean just an example of like
imagine someone says okay you have to go
fight someone to the death but you can
only use knives and so both of you walk
into the room you have a knife and then
the person who you're fighting brought a
gun and you say hey ref that's unfair
this person brought a gun and you're
yelling about how unfair it is at the
same time they shoot you and they and
they win the fight so we can yell about
how like unfair things are and say you
know we just want to be left alone and
follow the rules and be like this but
these people again again will take
advantage and they don't they don't live
by the same rules that you and i live by
so that's why we have to be on the
aggressive and say that you know like
like it's about talking about the the
drugs and the guns and things
it's like
you know when when you allow behavior
that is
bad for people in a society and this is
people are probably going to think i
sound fairly authoritarian but when you
allow degeneracy in some societies and
and you allow them to run rampant as
they kind of have in
america and the west in many ways
then you will have a society that even
if they're left alone in their own homes
it bleeds out into the rest of the world
and so that's really what we've got in
in the west today is that you let people
do all these things and say it's all
okay and then it bleeds out everywhere
else and now again you have this stuff
with the kids and it's really disgusting
what are your plans for the next year do
you have anything up and coming are you
just working on your online platform are
you writing anything what are your goals
working on my next book actually is my
biggest goal
and that's been a challenge
because this next book
is
it's not even like a conservative book
the way that i'm trying to to frame it
it's a very like us versus them type of
book elites versus us
and so it's been hard to
to to find people who want to support
that type of message i will say even
after how well my last book did and so
that's been difficult but really
hammering in on that and trying to get
trying to get signed there is really
what i'm looking at for this year and i
think that it's i i'd say this first
because i think that this book
especially for the audience i have which
is many people who are younger who
probably haven't heard a lot of this
stuff before is going to be a really
changing book for this country
um wow how old is your is your audience
on average
yeah i think i have about 50 percent of
my audience that's under 34.
and so the rest is older than that so
yeah so it's a pretty good amount of
people who are actually pretty young and
when you look at conservative politics
in general yeah you know it's definitely
not that young so
for me to have an audience of that age
is is pretty cool
actually yeah you know
and i hate to just like oh you're making
things for young people like that's what
you're doing you know i i don't really
like that i'm just glad that young
people are actually coming around to
understand some of the things that we're
talking about
yeah yeah
that's cool
okay
i didn't ask anything on my giant
list of questions
i know i mean you guys sent us some
topics and i didn't get any of that
oh yeah
sorry
don't worry about it who's your fiance
and why don't you like dr oz and what's
wrong with elon musk
i still can't believe you didn't like
harry potter though that's just it's not
cool harry potter was amazing the story
was amazing and they're i swear they're
a christian were you one of those people
who were like harry potter's evil
because there are witches in it
no no no listen i grew up an atheist my
entire life okay
if i would have thought harry potter had
gotten it
uh then i probably would have disliked
it even more at the time when it was
coming out so oh okay then let's do this
and we can like close off with this
how did you switch from atheism to being
a christian what happened
it was during covid and i actually i
you know you when you're in the
conservative space there's so many
people who are christian many of them
fake christians just going to be honest
with you at least in the leadership
positions
and so
i was someone who kind of considered
myself a fake christian a little bit
and you know i was saying that i was
kind of religious but wasn't really
doing anything so when covet hit i was
home alone i decided to order the quran
and then order the bible to read both
and so i ended up reading the bible and
i read the four gospels and it's really
like with anything that when you get any
sort of type of information presented to
you
and you either have to make a choice you
either ignore the information you accept
it as truth or you think that it's false
and so what i did after i read it i said
okay i think that this is true
and i'm going to to change my life
because of it
and i decided to to get baptized
that was about a year ago a year ago
like or a year and a couple months ago i
got baptized in hermosa beach california
by pastor jack kibbs and
it was a one of the greatest decisions i
ever made was to do that you know your
life gets harder doing that but it's
it's well worth it
so what changed
well it's
you know i think a lot of people still
expect that
christianity is supposed to make your
life better in some ways you know the
life that you're living now while you're
here on this earth in your physical body
that is supposed to make your life
better
because now you believe in god and he's
going to come and he's going to answer
your prayers and he's going to make it
better but in a lot of ways your life's
get your life gets harder because now
essentially you're living by certain
tenets
from the bible from scripture
that
are different than the way you were
living before and to live up to those
standards is actually more difficult and
so your life doesn't actually get easier
and you know being someone who believes
in something strongly that other people
actually don't really believe in and
being kind of in some ways against the
world the world hates you for what you
believe in uh it makes your life harder
you know especially if you're a strong
christian like i am and or my fiance is
or any of the other strong religious
people who really
get down to it people will hate you for
what you believe and they will hate you
for the values i mean they are hating
people who are pro-life right now that
you'll see i mean going and protesting
out of out of justice's houses and
screaming at them intimidating judges
breaking federal code i mean that's what
happens when you stand up for life and
when you stand up for things that are
biblically sound
so it gets tougher but the payoff i
believe is much better
i would say you're saved seems like a
pretty good payoff
yeah exactly that's that's that's
there's nothing better than that you
know if jesus if jesus died
for your sins on the cross and you read
the four gospels and you believe that
then you really have no other choice but
to give your life to him and so that's
what i did
wow so that was over covid interesting
yeah yeah
do you think there's a resurgence in
christianity and do you think part of
that is
because of
you know the chaos that we're seeing out
there
oh definitely a hundred percent i every
all young people that you talk to
nowadays are incredibly nihilist
most of them think that there is no
purpose in life everything is
meaningless and they don't really want
to do anything they have no passion or
drive they move to some urban city and
again become an uber driver a girl on
only fans or they work for some big mega
corporation that's owned by a bigger
mega corporation and they there's no
passion there and so everyone feels
pretty down about their lives and so
they need some sort of meaning in their
lives and so really they choose either
leftism
and and marxism and the communism and
all these social justice stuff they
choose that or they choose christianity
and this is why i think christianity is
actually very tied to conservatism
but but they choose christianity because
it gives their life meaning just like
that is a religion the left leftism is
also a religion in exactly the same way
people are naturally religious you know
that they have been for for
thousands and thousands of years you
know you used to have weather gods and
and then the greek gods all these sorts
of things and then you get christianity
and islam and
all of that people are naturally
religious so they will be inclined to go
towards something and right now the
biggest religion is leftism but many
people are seeing a resurgence in
christianity because
of that and then also many of the
churches in america at least that have
been these evangelical churches that
have prayed preach this this feel-good
christianity life is not supposed to be
hard come in and get your free coffee
that type of christianity or failing
because people want the the real give it
to me straight type of christianity or
catholicism and so i think there's a
resurgence and actually strong
a strong christian faith in this country
i hope it's enough
yeah well we'll see i have no idea
things are pretty crazy are you are you
uh
a protestant or practicing catholicism
no not practicing catholicism so pretty
much just non-denominational
non-denominational okay yeah so i guess
you could say protestant
yeah cool
okay well
do you have anything else you want to
talk about
um
i don't think so
i still want to get you and you and your
dad on on prageru for documentary about
masculinity
still doable
yeah we'll set that up we'll talk yeah
yeah yeah
we should do it we should do it um yeah
if if anyone wants to find you where
should they go if they don't follow you
already
you can go anywhere on social media at
the will wit and you can order my book
how to win friends and influence enemies
on amazon barnes noble anywhere really
books are sold
okay thank you very much for coming on
i'll have you and your fiance on or
potentially wife on
when i have a studio in miami
let's hope life
we can cross our fingers
yeah yeah definitely
[Music]
you